Cool, so it looks like we found
a service with the data that we need.
But to get that data it looks like we
need to download a complicated form,
then read our results off a map,
or download a spreadsheet.
I'm not sure how we're
going to use this service.
>> Well, why can't we just embed
the spreadsheet into our app?
>> Well, I think we could, but
it would be an updating nightmare.
Especially for users.
I mean every single time there's
new data, we'd have to re-download
the spreadsheet, recompile the app,
then republish it to Google Play.
Not to mention, every single time there
was new data, users would also have to
update their apps every single time
we updated, which was like daily.
>> Yeah, talk about a poor experience.
>> That is a problem.
Well, perhaps we'll just have our
app pick up some drive-through data.
>> [LAUGH] What do you mean?
>> Get this.
You can think of a data source
like a fast food restaurant.
You know, the kind with indoor
seating and a drive-through.
>> Okay.
>> You see,
when you're not sure what
you want at a restaurant,
you probably want to go inside,
look at the menu, talk to the staff, and
they'll take care of
bringing the food to you.
>> Okay.
>> But when you know exactly what food
you want, you're probably okay going
through the drive-thru making a precise
order and then getting your food
returned to you all nicely
packaged up at the pick-up window.
>> Are you sure we're still
talking about earthquakes?
>> Absolutely.
>> For example, when you navigate to
the USGS website and fill out the form
querying for what earthquakes you want,
that's like going in and
sitting down at the restaurant You're
getting the human friendly experience.
>> Okay, I got you.
>> But
if you're another computer program, or
an app that wants to use data from USGS,
then there's the drive-through window.
You see, you can customize a request for
data and it gets returned to you in
a simple format that a program
can easily understand.
>> Hm, let me think about that.
So you mean there's dine-in data for
humans, and drive-through data for apps?
>> Absolutely.
And the drive-through window is kind of
like an application programming
interface.
>> Right, an API.
So it's basically a way for
another application to talk
to a service via code.
>> Yup.
>> So, burgers?
>> Absolutely, let me call.
>> Let's do it.